and
good evening everybody 7:30 make a start
emergency should we be required to
evacuate the building would you please
leave the building while the nearest
wavelengths there were two fire exits in
this room if you need to evacuate the
room by the door of our escape staircase
to peace health code and miles in case
the stairs are wet or slippery if anyone
is unable to use the stairs please do
lift simply formally and public car park
outside of the sitting suite please do
not delay your calculation to collect
any belongings please do not return to
the building until given permission to
do so by council stop please note that
this meeting will be recorded and
people 70
apologies for absence we have apologies
from counselor mrs. Christine Mason and
counselor John Mason
cancel cancel
substitute members we've had counselor
mrs. Foy
stupid counselor mrs. Mason and count
the corset such - for counselor mr.
Mason non members attending counsel
catwalk and counselor Lucas guild
agenda item number four which are
minutes of the meeting held in 30 March
2010 take place in South Asian swimmers
members happy place minister signed
[Music]
agenda item five receive declarations of
interest which include any grouping
decoration
sure
Oh
- Mila
nothing
find something number six which is the
review of the ICT contact this is an
update members from the projecting
everybody wouldn't be given a copy of
their home without using contact long
way to $0.03
[Music]
378 600 minutes for the meetings of the
predicting had we've got three enters
tonight present you on that project team
members have all had a chance to read
hopefully
you can talk cancer nipple if that's
possible
I'll just give a brief give you thinking
we called it in to review because
obviously we weren't happy with the
progress that have been made and the
dates it slipped so we scoped out what
exactly had been done and where we were
with the milestones on on the project
and we've we've spoken we've got a few
meetings and spoken with the portfolio
holder as well
the projects going and we've raised a
few concerns that you'll see in the
report and that we should get an update
on at the next meeting and really
there's any questions I can answer them
or other members of
24:20 next meeting
I'll go there oh sorry it's a wife as I
already promised it will be after the
action
do you know if it says every boys all
DC's responsibilities one red star
feminine belongs to the three six do you
know everybody's not positive I believe
from the recent email that I received
not everyone's been moved across and yet
as yet
but you can either they were giving you
an education Aston you know I will do
that
start certainly I think there's a few
that
the system remembers we were trying to
get as many as possible I think that's
probably still some
[Music]
another question I had it
the report said the remember a standing
position playing engagement 206s
circumstances
of Gina Poole causing loss just was that
unexpected projects and they were
expected only in voices from the
character has been negotiation
that's what I figured
and is it juice me I don't have
I don't know I honestly don't know the
impression it was I would like to say
that person
I was under the impression that had been
faced because she shouted it was a great
thing
and also don't notice once it is there
there's currently trying problems at
prison to assist with any proposed
terrify on that the Chromebooks now when
we spoke about app we know that the
portfolio holder George has tried anyone
but also I don't think I think that the
view is that not everyone would get them
if they wanted to use their own devices
am i right the center
I think it's an option if you're like my
production 365 meant the people could
use their own devices and I believe some
members have yeah yeah have got their
own device and heads three six five yeah
so it's not actually yeah and also on
the back of that question
and there was some discussion about the
security of those devices and that was a
question that's been asked and that we
would be presented with at the next
meeting
that's crazy about members on top of all
that web systems really thank you
so did you think so a minute yeah no
it's not special about the abilities
which we've lost
as a moment is one of thing
once we've talked the update on the
security and where we're at
to the vision of the heart of using the
health system to the cloud
is the
where it's going as we can see the
recall
facilities was we
get
[Music]
everything's up more painful settle
removing that lies which is probably
subject for now
and sustaining just bring you back to is
everybody on the on 365 system
the ones that are not I've been I was to
come even with the with their iPads to
get onto the system so I'm Connor 39
councilors turn up all the same time
sort of thing so it's arrangement get
the catfish to go to the system over
there
just
they trying to be okay
[Music]
the
was it
come really commendable
kisses
the idea is to do maybe a license
yeah
this is too easy
it might be there like an email just to
sort of prompt members to get it sorted
possibly yes what can possibly come
Thank You mr. chairman point three point
three mentions support domains
agreements and license in third-party
companies is it the intention to knows
on expiry of those that they've been
transferred to it you should
[Music]
Jonah's up again I
council use a number of software
companies to provide sup in the specific
permissions
Edge's serve would be out of time those
are though because they will still
continue to be canceled rate just to
clarify that
edu server more about the clean for
structurally life and the service that
they sit application support will be
done by the software provider that's
what was explained to us
just one other thing as the question to
do to enable feeling someone who in my
work life is having getting GDR notice
these ministers couple things
every little bit juniors you've got
accounts of GDP a particularly we've got
the staff perhaps keeping just a general
notion was how do you feel from meeting
so far do you know the Council on top of
GDP are so so we did raise the issue of
GDP are it was obviously we all know how
important it is and I believe there was
a project already on going to GDP yes we
are we didn't over the last few months
and implementation of a plan in place
and the council has
to client
[Music]
so if I went up to privacy notices
remote act training the staff
we were looking at training levels
I have drafted something the members
a little careful so that yes there has
been that implementation project in
places
last year it's coming here to me
they still not want to be done and even
after the implementation date still
aren't going
for us yes
we're not quite there yet
one thing that we did them raisins we
didn't have a big concern about was the
bring your own devices and the security
of those devices and gdpr and I'm sure
that the to be covering covering that
issue yes I'm not an expert on
as opposed on Steam unity
as we have device
actually justice movie
I see some currency versus just about
today
[Music]
the other members building questions
members of the project team
Thank You bossing questions
remember there is a recommendation which
is just to know that the
I think that's happening to that
recommendation
item number seven it's the key decision
document we're gonna just have a copy of
that or have they got one too
we [ __ ] some copies if anybody needs
go down the list that was 119 removing
the credit debit card payment has been
on there for a couple of months and last
month it was whether the decision was
moved to do this year to May
yes there's a brief conversation with it
this was good
I'm going to be a decision
definitely
they say some negotiation
yeah I think he's there seeking
clarification couldn't provide
and then sitting in study
so come June in might be taking off
2:18 you'll see there is a position on
the 4th of April that's what we've gone
3:18 is the pay mine too seven air
quality project outline final business
case and that's not - until November
2009 thing
4:18 the street scene enforcement
strategy that was issued on the 4th of
April as well and then finally the
two new ones 5:18
accounting application in policy
again I mean there's already basically
around free consultations it's the post
consultation document which
come inspect both public and
stakeholders and
presentation as we speak and that key
decision day postponed
and then finally we have 618
environmental health service bang 2000
1990 this is what we see every year
Peter
those ones out came just to turn down a
bit
thank you
I mean as a general sense there's not
much to really recall there is already a
coupla lines emitted into the gym than
July meeting and also the project teams
the three project teams listed down
there they're having meetings and a
variety of meetings review the
Constitution will be next week
and then the voice of the councilman
I could be twenty first year
any more to add on that
okay without members item number nine
which is approval of the committee's
annual report it's been circulated to
members had a chance to look at
council point twister so I think it's
just a mum
checkpoint one I've wear that we do
mention about building control bar
justly deserve to be expanded upon bit
more than vehicle as we did have the
mean and they the noise the problems
they have been and also to know how they
had to improve the surface and they're
gonna come back YouTube so I thought
well just expanding on that a bit
okay
you never comment your numbers or with
anything that they feel what's getting
included moves changed so our members
happen Felicity council with the
amendment of council mr. foresters made
this is to bring the present puppet be
excluded from the meeting the remaining
business on the grounds that it's empty
information as defined in paragraph 3
part 1 schedule 12 equal Government Act
1972 will be disclosed